you had a heck of a father's day
yesterday his son tj's got a new heart
and i love greg olsen he'll be joining
us in hour number three and i love this
man as well and couldn't be more happy
for him
uh because he's got a new book uh about
uh
called center stage my most fascinating
interviews from a-rod
to jay-z as a host of the award-winning
show center stage on yes growing up in
new york
as i did with as he did as well a dream
job would be to be talking sports every
single day
um as he does and also be the voice
of the new york yankees as he is and i
watch him all the time with my kids
because yes network is always on in my
house
he's michael kay who i've known forever
in a day how are you michael k
i'm great rich belated happy father's
day same to you man
thanks the same to you what were you
doing uh oh that's right
you were calling a walk off triple play
i saw triple play
and then uh my wife and kids took me out
to dinner after that so it was a nice
father's day a lot of walk-offs
you've i i imagine you've you we i i
know you've called triple plays because
yankees have had three of them this year
but
is that your first walk-off triple play
of your car that's the first one i think
the yankees have had one in
1903 in 1913 so i was a little young man
but uh i i had only seen one triple play
in my life before this year
the randy velarde unassisted triple play
even as a fan
so uh three and then two in like four
days kind of amazing
it is man especially since chapman uh or
aldous chapman had a visit to the mound
by
uh by aaron boone and then
the trainer and it looked like he might
be coming out double barrel action in
the pen and his 11th pitch
of the appearance with just two strikes
thrown was the triple play
i mean that is amazing i i might not
have ended well
yesterday because he didn't have great
stuff and then they all seemed like it
was bothering him
but boone joked afterwards that he said
i didn't go out there checking on his
nail i said
just throw a three ball right here so he
did that's it i love it
well i mean and plus in this day and age
michael we i just can't tell anymore if
a pitcher doesn't have it because
they're not using what they normally put
on a baseball
what is your perspective uh of what
major league baseball is attempting to
do
certainly since garrett cole has been
right there in the front and center in
the middle of the all of this
michael i don't like it i understand why
they're doing it the the thing i don't
like about it is why are you doing it in
the middle of june
because you're asking pitchers to change
something that they've been doing for a
long time even those that don't
weaponize it into spin rate
there are people that actually use stuff
on the ball to get a grip
and now you're asking them not to do
that if you if you believe tyler class
now
it could have really negative
consequences as well
but i do understand what they're doing
because the first two months of the
season
it was really tough to watch baseball
there's no action
fastball uh strikeout fastball walk
fastball home run
that's not good it's not good for the
game uh there's very little action very
little balls put in play
so they had to do something and i think
they were desperate that's why they're
doing this in the middle of the season
yeah because i think somebody took it
too far i mean people were taking it way
too far i mean
that's spider tac stuff i've seen videos
about what it actually is you
you know general contractors use it to
build houses i mean pitchers shouldn't
use it to get a grip on a baseball i
mean that's just insane
well i was told by a couple people that
the grip
that the pitchers had on baseballs like
last year you could really tell because
the ballparks were empty which was
terrible but
if you've ever ripped velcro that's what
it sounded like a ball coming off a
pitcher's hand
that's how much adhesive they had and
that does increase spin rate so
uh spin right is something that makes a
pitch a little bit more unhittable
and that's why you saw a batting average
for the entire major league baseball
equal to what it was in 1968. so
something had to give rather than moving
the mound back two feet or a foot or
anything like that
and this was their first step what are
you hearing about the actual uh
manner in which they're going to you
know uh
check for this stuff like you can have
strip searches which is going to be fine
r-rated games i don't know nobody really
yesterday speaking to the media derek
cole wasn't sure exactly how they're
going to enforce this but
i mean if we worry about pace of play
rich really not good to keep stopping
the game to check a picture so
i hope they do that between innings or
whatever the case may be
but it's going to be ugly it's not just
pa it's not pace of play anymore it's
quality play i mean you just said it i
mean
there there was a game uh look i i i say
it to you on the air i text it to you
off the air i truly mean it like
you're you're the voice in in my house
uh maybe more than
mine you know i mean we're we're
constantly watching yankee games
and um you know there was a an inning
where i think it was yankees raise ninth
inning
uh game on the line two men on two men
out and a ball had yet to be put in play
you know what i'm saying and even so
even the exciting stuff you got this
feeling in your gut saying something's
off here
something's just not right even when the
excitement is there
michael there's something has to be done
something had to be done yeah and i'm
wondering
how a lot of people complain about the
launch angle and the three true outcomes
but
smarter people than me have come up with
the fact
that against the pitching the way it is
right now
the best the most efficient way to score
is to hit a home run because you're not
going to string together five or six
hits
with one reliever after the other coming
in from the bullpen hitting 98 miles an
hour
and in case that stops in the event that
that stops
then hitting will return to the game and
awesome you might have to outlaw shifts
and i think
i hate to legislate against people being
smarter than other people
but i think that's what you do because
the bottom line is you've got these
these ivy league grads finding the most
efficient way to win
but they are not entrusted with making
the game entertaining no the most
efficient way to win is not the most
entertaining way but that's uh
you know i i'll push back on that even
though you might not believe that but
michael k here on the rich eisen show
and we'll talk about center stage
in a second his uh new book about his uh
interviews
uh with some of the best and brightest
uh right here on the rich eisen show
michael k
i'm gonna push back just a little bit
here because the yankees of the
the tory era they put the ball in play
they always put the ball in play and not
ever
they never really had a a league leader
in home runs but they did hit home runs
but everybody did
and they had pitching do you think the
yankees of those years that you were
calling
um michael k could win now
in baseball paul o'neill thinks that
they could win but i will tell you this
it's a lot harder to hit now than it was
then
really so i i understand your pushback
is not really even pushback it's almost
a confirmation
the game has changed so much that you
remember those teams rich
what they would do is they would work
the starting pitcher
to the point that the starting pitcher
would be knocked out in the fifth inning
right
and then they would beat up on the
underbelly of the bullpen
there is no underbelly of bullpens
anymore everybody throws 95 miles an
hour
it's hard to hit it just is i don't know
if you can hit like that now o'neill
claims he said on the air
anybody who says they can't take the
ball against shift is lying but then
i've had mark to share on my show and he
goes
it's not that easy to do and also i'm
paid to hit over the shift not through
it right
well plus i i'm paying a ticket to see
somebody
hit hit a ball and it goes safely not
bunt
you know just because the left field
line is wide open like that's not what i
that's not what i want to do either but
all right michael k here on the rich
eisen show congrats on this book sir
um center stage what are you um most
proud of
about this michael the names on the on
the book cover are remarkable to say
i mean the the the the a-list guess that
we've had and you know you doing the
show it's not an easy thing to do
especially
when you get a person that has to commit
in person
to be there for over an hour it's like
an hour and a half commitment
and uh you know we started out twenty
years ago our first guest was steve
young
and i couldn't think of a better guess
to start with he was the best and
he's in the book uh and just the the
amount of guests that we've had the
things that we've uncovered and i just
found this outreach yes sir
two weeks ago so it's not even in the
book we have mike tyson on
and tyson on stage was alternately
crying and laughing uproariously
flipping between happy and sad
there were times i was sitting there
thinking it was going to hit me
the audience was sitting on the edge of
their seats i left that interview and go
wow that was raw that was just visceral
and then i found out two weeks ago that
that show aired on yes
and a gentleman by the name of spike lee
was watching
the show ended and he called up tyson
immediately said
that's a show one man show on broadway i
want to produce
and that's actually what tyson on
broadway began no kidding
yeah i didn't know that until two weeks
ago did you you did you'd lea
so thus you didn't get a piece let alone
a house seat for that you know i'm glad
you asked because we think alike
i know spike and i like spike you know i
was on that stage too spike
how about something something for the
effort well i mean how about a one man
what would the one man michael k
play be called oh what would that be one
on sentence
no it would be called i don't eat
ketchup it could be that i got it k
doesn't always mean strikeout
ladies and gentlemen michael k round of
applause
right there i like it um so yeah i i
we had tyson here what was that about
five six years ago i think and
uh that was back uh in a day where the
radio clock that i had which is i'm sure
i know i'm talking your language there
as well
we'd have to take a break in the middle
of the hour
and tyson came on 20 minutes into the
hour
and i had to take a break at some point
during the interview and the question is
is when do you do it when do you not
and i asked him a question about you
know what would you
tell the old mike tyson back in the day
that you know
that he wouldn't know right now and he
goes well the old mike tyson wouldn't
listen to me and
i i said why and he said because you
know
um that that he definitely uh
didn't listen to people back then and i
asked him how many rounds could he give
me right now he goes i don't want to
even think about it he goes why because
he said i might i might hurt somebody
that's when i took the break that's a
good break
i'm like we'll be right back i mean like
and that 60 seconds was like what do you
say to somebody
you know what i mean like i always found
that always an awkward moment when
there's a guest sitting right there
and i imagine shooting something over an
hour and a half you had moments like
that all the time with some of your
guests
you have to break with tyson and like
you know after he's crying
what do you say to him oh by the way
beautiful weather huh
how would you like a broadway play that
could be something i've always liked
i i'm sure that you're like this as well
like when letterman go to break and lean
in and
i want to know what he leaned in and
said that's the stuff i'm curious about
yes uh the one time um uh
i was on letterman he leans into me as
the commercial break and he goes thanks
that was it that was it so people at
home like what's he saying a wretch so
what'd you say
thanks uh it's also some of the names
here are some of the all-time great
yankees
like bera and what were those like what
what do you
have memories of those moments to me
that that i take out of it and i explain
this in the book is just
you when you're around somebody for a
long time and an hour is a long time
you realize why they they are who they
are and i think that's that's the crux
of the book as well
but with yogi he was so nice to
everybody i mean he made everybody
feel like they were the most important
person in the world so we have a comic
that comes out and warms up the audience
before the show his name is pete dominic
and he brought his father
a world war ii veteran who loved yogi so
i brought the dad
into the dressing room before the show
and yogi made him feel like the most
important person in the world
and pete told me that's one of my dad's
biggest moments in life
and i just think that's what yogi berra
is about just a sweet
gentle man who never let his celebrity
get the best of him and i've seen the
celebrity get the best of a lot of
people
but not yogi bear who would you want
that you didn't get
we're still working with you i know
springsteen
uh billy joel um jerry seinfeld
and michael jordan seinfeld i don't
understand why we don't have them
because we've had larry david on and
larry and i have come
to have a really great relationship
he'll text me during yankee games
screaming about a move that aaron boone
made
right and so he he obviously had a good
experience on the show but
i don't know if jerry has an aversion
because of the yankee connection with
yes
he's such a big met fan we have not been
able to get him off is that right
i mean it could it could be that it
could be a met yankee thing which you
have to respect too
right well you know what then i've got
to call in gary cohn from the you know
the bullpen and have him host that show
i mean you know you wouldn't want to do
that michael let's let's be honest here
let's just put on let's put every card
out of my death grip
[Music]
ah springsteen would be the winner too
right and but and billy joel what would
you ask him man
what would be well i signed off my radio
show every day life is a series of
hellos and goodbyes i'm afraid it's time
for goodbye again so i'd ask him where
that line came from okay
very good he could basically say i don't
remember i was drunk he could say that
you know back then
and then i'll go it's time for break
okay so uh this is your off day and then
well not not for your
radio show what when do you when you
when do i see you again michael when do
i hear your voice
um at seven with uh with david cohn for
yankees royals
mike derek cole on the mount there we go
all right
his qu his i feel i i i i go back and
forth i feel for the guy i mean that
that
you know that question that i guess was
it pete david off that asked him like
you know jeffy
from the post ken david off that bad i
thought you know what i didn't think it
was an illegitimate question
i don't like rich is that this guy's
being made to be the face of it
he's far from the only person and for
some reason
because of josh donaldson he's the face
of it i i just don't think that's fair
and i don't know if you've ever
interviewed him he's really smart
and i just think he was caught between
what he wanted to say and kind of what
he was advised to say
and nothing came out the yankees don't
make a lot of players available
nationally michael you know that
i mean they do not it's just that simple
because i'm as a die-hard yankee fan as
there is i would love to interview every
last one of them and it's very difficult
i wish you could get him on because he's
i'd love to talking with him about
pitching is like a master's michael he
was a kid
he was like me going to yankee stadium
except i i just you know i
i don't have a 300 million dollar
contract because i uh you know so the
yankees
you know haven't hired me my heart is
really close though you know
my spin rate's a little off you know
that's my problem
hey mike you're the best bud i
appreciate it i'll i will
i'm there every night you know should so
do you answer larry because sometimes
you don't answer me when i text you
michael uh i i get frowned upon for
being on the phone sometimes but i will
answer i do have bosses you know
well how are you paying attention see i
have add so i can pay attention with a
thousand things at once but they don't
get that
all right michael look for my text
tomorrow night take care of yourself
buddy you got it say hello to the family
you see you too that's uh michael k
everybody michael
k everybody hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here